DeSantis has a great answer to Trump
which is hey if I was such a bad
Governor especially during covid why did
you move your whole family down to
Florida during my governorship so you
talked about uh changing our tone a
little bit with former president Trump I
don't believe you mentioned him here by
name tonight but does this mean you're
going to be a bit more aggressive with
campaigning against him so look I'm
going to respond to
attacks I mean if if you say Cuomo did a
better job with covid then Florida did
first of all that's not what he used to
say this is like new like six months ago
he would have never said that right he
used to say how great Florida was hell
his whole family moved to Florida under
my governorship are you kidding me
that's a good line
now of course Trump has had a presence
in Florida for a long time he obviously
bought the Mar-A-Lago club a long time
ago was the winter white house from the
beginning of Trump's presidency but it's
a good one they spent a lot more time in
Florida